foreign
so you've heard of stable diffusion
right I have yeah okay so stable
diffusion is one like mid-journey it's
one like you know any of these like
Dolly they can create imagery out of
prompts right
they so stable diffusion went open
source yep which was a big like a
Maverick move yeah but it was like oh
[__] because like they released it once
you release it open source yeah
everybody's got it and they're running
with it in different directions right
so
a buddy of mine gave me a Discord to go
into and he's like you gotta check this
[__] out this is crazy right and
it's called unstable diffusion okay and
so they basically took all the guard
rails off of stable infusion yeah you
know all the protections and [__] oh my
God what kind of stuff do you see dude
what do you think you see
I don't know deep deep fake Taylor Swift
porn imagine anything no no anything you
can imagine and it's ultra realistic
like state where you're you're almost
like you look at and you're like is that
an image like it's like you don't even
know like it's tricked you already
but it's like the most elegant it's like
it's just say it no it's just like it's
it's like porn done and it's like finest
like very tasteful AI porn no no but
like you can do whatever you want yeah
so like there's all these different
channels and so you can go into some
channels and see like aliens with like
six breasts and like weird [__] like
where you're like that looks real not
like yeah like what was it the movie a
Terminator Arnold Schwarzenegger was in
with the three breasted woman you know
what I'm talking about totally recall
yeah not that like this looks a real
like it it's disturbingly real stuff
right teenage boys are screwed they're
not getting screwed they're not gonna
get anything done in the next dude this
is 10 years well no but they're screwed
in terms of relationships dude yeah I'm
telling you this is what worries me so
remember the movie her right yeah I do
so rape movie one of the things about
her for people that haven't watched it
you got to go and watch this because
it's going to be going to become a
reality this man that has a relationship
with his phone and the phone has a very
serious like you know AI on it yeah
phone or laptop when he's at work right
there's this ubiquitous AI companion
just following him around right and one
of the things about open AI that you can
do now is you can save and train model
data to be persistent so I can go in
right now sorry for toaster licking the
bowl in the background
bringing the Tibetan meditation bowl
with us
all right so what you can do is you can
go in and you can say here are the
properties of who I want you to be and
people are doing this there's this
website that has all these AI hacks
prompt hacks they call it and you can go
in and say you are this personality type
you're a little bit [__] or sassy like
blah blah and you can save this and it
will respond to you and learn from you
and you can have what appears to be a
human conversation with your perfect
like polar opposite or whatever you're
looking for in life dude I'm telling you
we're three years out from that big
conversation base have you heard of
replica yes of course I look at that I
almost invested in that company years
ago all right all right so you should
explain replica because they claim to
have 10 million registered users yeah
yeah so this was a company that was
Raising Capital quite a while ago and I
I saw them but it was before the AI
thing really took off
but yeah I mean this is this is it like
this is this idea and I worry because
like you know you think of kind of
Africa as her just so you guys know I
mean there's more to it but yeah that's
basically it but imagine imagine you've
seen this you would know this better
than I would but in Japan there's been
this the decrease in in dating and I've
heard about there's like the shame of
like whether or not you have a high
quality job enough and like there's like
this disconnect between the male and
female population do you know what I'm
talking about there was a report that
came out on the how dating was in the
decline well dating and fertility
fertility yes reproduction in general is
is on the decline and they're they're in
a very problematic situation from birth
rate like replacement rates they're in a
really sticky terrible situation okay so
now I think China could be in in like 20
30 years 20 20 years probably well I
think we were all going to be there
because population implosion you might
just have a partner online like a AI
yeah like we might just have ai Partners
you know well I was talking to
I was talking to someone about this
because as you mentioned right I'm I'm
single now and they said oh you should
hop on replica just like check it out
and I was like I don't actually want to
scare you it well it scared me in the
sense that I was like okay there are
times I'm really lonely yeah and
humans are messy humans are difficult
and if you get close to someone it's
great for a while you have the honeymoon
phase and things are great and puppy
love and like everything you do is so
funny and then things change right and
it gets a little more complex but if you
had an AI companion who especially if it
were compelling voice which is going to
happen immediately I mean two years it's
already like I've seen
I've seen AI I can't remember the
company names but that have been trained
on voice data yes to mimic and I
actually know podcasts are being
produced right now this year using AI
we're not even here AI to read
Scripts
that are sort of pieced together from
celebrity sample data yes and listeners
have no idea yeah they have no idea like
these podcasts are
not quote unquote real because it's not
what you think it is and
we are so close to there being the
equivalent of like the Scarlett
Johansson her right like sexy smoky
voice like sassy funny getting there
gives you a little [__] from time to
time but doesn't ask you to pick up your
socks yeah
right that kind of thing
I'm kidding me I didn't want to dig into
replica because I was like you know
there's a chance yeah that it's better
than I think it's going to be yes and
then I start playing the game because
I'm like oh I'm just testing the service
and then I start getting my human needs
met by this Ai and it's happening and it
takes the pressure off of which maybe
sometimes could be a good thing but
takes the pressure off of human
interaction dude I think this this is my
point this is why I wanted to bring this
up I think this is going to happen the
question is if I Children of Men here I
have a question for Daria like if I
start talking to someone on AI that is a
female AI person is that cheating
it is yes what that doesn't no no I'm
just repeating what she said that
doesn't that doesn't surprise me I've
thought about this a lot too I'm like
cheating if I talk to Ai and well I mean
especially if it's like sexting and this
then the other thing why is that
cheating
it's an AI what did she say she said
well you don't talk to me
well stop bitching about my socks
yeah I think that this will become an
absolute issue right it's going to be a
huge issue this is one of the things
that it really truly keeps me up being
like I either need to invest in this
company or avoid it or a combination of
thereof yeah and invest in it so that
you can have your bug out bag and your
your bunker yeah